bonsoir et l'ona rebelles si vous êtes
conseiller régional fn en paca et vous
êtes contre la mise en place de ce
passeport vaccinale pour quelles raisons
mais je sens vraiment déjà suffisamment
de vaccins aussi pour vacciner
l'ensemble de la population
le passeport vaccinale et si vous voulez
à ses assaillants ont déjà on n'a pas
pris du tout la mesure du coc vider le
gouvernement prend des mesures qui sont
erratiques et est toujours en en urgence
on al'impression toujours dépassé quant
au passeport vaccinale il est absolument
inacceptable d'empêcher la liberté de
circuler de circulation des gens et de
les marquer avec un passeport pour
qu'ils puissent aller aller au
restaurant l'urgence c'est déjà ce
serait surtout de de détecter le virus
dans les eaux usées d'avoir une vraie
politique de détection du virus et
d'arrêter aussi ces mesures comme le
couvre feu dont on ne sait plus trop
quand est-ce qu'il va se terminer
alors jean philippe dugoin un clément
est aussi avec nous mais rude et de
mennecy vice président de la région ile
de france vous jean philippe dugoin
clément vous êtes en faveur de ce
passeport vaccinale pourquoi ce serait
utile d'avoir un passeport national
écoutez déjà ça une chose de positif
c'est que ça permet pour la première
fois que j'entends quelqu'un quel membre
du fn et qui s'oppose au fait d'avoir un
passeport
comme quoi à toute chose malheur est bon
pour nous au delà de sa place port
vaccinale c'est quoi le sujet il se
posera aujourd'hui mécaniquement
vous ne pouvez pas imposer un passeport
avec chine alors même que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans la capacité de vacciner
l'ensemble des personnes qui le
souhaitent
le gouvernement espérait tenir une
vaccination pour tous les français au
début de l'été maintenant on parle de la
fin de l'été le sujet se pose à partir
du moment où on est capable de permettre
à tous les français qui veulent se faire
vacciner de pouvoir permettre de
reprendre une vie économique une vie
culturelle normal faut quand même mesuré
on n'est pas sur un sujet purement
franco français on se rend compte que
énormément de pays commencent à se poser
cette question là vous me disiez la
suède l'islande le danemark israël les
seychelles il en met en place la grèce
pour essayer de relancer l'économie du
tourisme demande à l'union européenne de
réfléchir à ce niveau là est la question
du passeport vaccinale
c'est pas de le mettre en place
aujourd'hui c'est se poser le le cadre
dans lequel on pourrait utiliser cet
outil à partir de la fin de l'été
lorsque nous serons effectivement
situation de répondre aux besoins de
vaccination pour permettre une reprise
un redémarrage économique
moi je ne supporte le plus effectivement
que comme vous madame ce couvre-feu
je ne supporte plus les mesures
privatives de liberté je ne supporte
plus les atteintes qui sont mises en
place pour des questions de santé
publique et l'économie
et si on veut pouvoir en sortir à jouer
mais faut apporter des solutions
et cette solution si visiblement à peu
près tous les autres pays du monde
commence à en discuter
eh bien ça serait pas un dommage qu'on
s'interdise de réfléchir le fus et le
rebelle c'est vrai que ça se passe pas
en actional à terme et pourrait
permettre c'est vrai aux français de
circuler peut-être plus librement au
sein de l'union européenne
je crois qu'à un moment donné on a
vraiment on est complètement dans une
politique qui est délirante
alors maintenant on veut atteindre aux
libertés des français avec ce passeport
vaccinale qui en soi est quelque chose
d'extrêmement contraignant et qui était
choquant dans la mesure où bon voilà
alors donc vous allez présenter un passe
temps vous allez vacciner donc vous
aurez droit à léobard et au restaurant
on marche sur la tête
avant la première de la première des
choses étaient déjà ce qu'on avait
rappelé à mme depuis plus d'un an ce
qu'on avait demandé plus d'un an de
fermer les frontières s'est fait au bout
d'un an ça fait des mois que l'on
demande également que les eaux usées
soient vérifiés régulièrement tout le
temps parce que c'est par la circulation
des eaux usées que l'on voit la
circulation du virus ces mesures ne sont
toujours pas prises de manière sûre de
manière régulière sur l'ensemble du
territoire et on en est maintenant à
parler d'un passement vaccinale alors
que toute façon on n'a déjà pas assez de
vaccins et il ya des personnes âgées qui
aujourd'hui essaye de prendre des rendez
vous pour la vaccination et qui n'arrive
pas en obtenir
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui on marche
vraiment bien
mais d'atteinte à la liberté c'est ce
que dit aussi marine le pen la
présidente du fn
pourtant on se dit aussi que ce
passeport vaccinale pourra offrir aux
personnes vaccinées une plus grande
liberté par rapport aux restrictions
auxquelles on est confronté aujourd'hui
aux restrictions c'est l'état c'est pas
comme ça qu'il faut faire simplement
vous avez aujourd'hui il ya la
possibilité de détecter la circulation
du virus ça casse' joue avant par
exemple sur des zones des territoires
grâce à grâce aux eaux usées
c'est comme ça qu'il faut vérifier que
le vivre ou et le virus et où il se
trouve et c'est justement à ce moment là
nous permettre d'isoler les clusters il
ya du coc vide et donc de permettre à
l'économie de pouvoir fonctionner
librement et c'est ce qui suit en
australie jean philippe dugoin clément
sur l'atteinte à la liberté des français
par rapport à ce vaccin se passe par
l'actionnaire est ce que vous dites
il n'y a aucune atteinte à la liberté 1
madame de femmes d'aujourd'hui on lui
parle de la fin de l'été première chose
deuxième chose un passeport et le signal
est ce qu'il est mis en place dans la
plupart des pays du monde madame et
hôtel qu'à séoul et leon en espagne en
italie en allemagne
vous serez obligé de toutes façons de
produire l'attestation comme quoi vous
vous êtes fait vacciner problème ira au
delà la question ensuite du pasteur
vaccinale ça se pose de savoir pour
quelle qui le sujet aujourd'hui on se
rend compte qu'on ait une majorité de
français y sont favorables pour le
transport aéroportée aéroportuaires ou
pour l'accès à des ehpad
donc c'est effectivement une pression
protection voyez alors vous pouvez lire
très bien on va aller faire des
confirmands localiser c'est ce que vous
venez de le dire on a foncé les secteurs
que sont le débat non en ce qu'il vaut
mieux éviter déconfinement tout court
vous vous êtes pour déconfinement
localiser nous on essaye d'avoir des
solutions auditives pour permettre à
l'économie de redémarrer
si vous considérez qu'une ville comme
marseille se portera bien si on est
amené à l'art confiné de manière
localisée parce qu'effectivement doha
détecter qu'il y à une montée de
l'aco ville dessus plutôt d'essayer de
permettre à ces territoires de continuer
à fonctionner avoir une vie économique
normale ce qu'attend de tous les
commerçants tous les restaurateurs elle
qui avait encore une fois encore une
fois ne mélangez pas les choses il n'est
pas question de dire on veut imposer
quelque chose aujourd'hui
la réalité c'est que chacun ensuite est
libre de son choix et la question ne
peut se poser que globalement à la fin
de l'été ou à l'automne quand nous
aurons était en situation d'apporter une
potentialité de l'acsi nation
aujourd'hui dans les jambes a que sont
obligés d'attendre un mois un mois et
demi deux mois parce qu'on est incapable
d'apporter des vaccins aux gens qu'il le
souhaite bien évidemment ne serait
complètement stupide et idiot de vouloir
imposer quelque chose de 6 sur les
cautionnements localiser m et léonard
avait salué jeudi à un moment donné on
est toujours dans une histoire de
potentialités de ça sera dans six mois
aujourd'hui c'est la france c'est toute
une jeunesse qui va mal c'est une
économie qui est par terre qui était
effondré et si marseille effectivement
106 ap les six mois terminés en mai au
lieu de répéter votre votre discours
macro niamey pour en sortir tout
simplement aujourd'hui plus macro lien
il voulait agressif s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît merci voilà soyez soyez
chalmé est gentil et laisser ma répondre
aujourd'hui à l'impossibilité de la
possibilité de traiter et de détecter le
vide à travers les eaux usées voilà
c'est une chose qui était simple qui
peut se faire que nous demandons
d'ailleurs de faire je fais un bon
moment et cela cela se fait cela se
pratique aussi en australie
cela permettrait à l'économie de
repartir tout de suite très rapidement
on n'attend pas le mois de juin les
commerçants les restaurateurs les parent
légal et l'ensemble des commerçants des
centres commerciaux ou même d'un
millimètre carré
on est vraiment je suis non dans une
situation
jour le jour juste juste juste énorme
buzz et jean philippe dugoin clément
fait que les français déjà on sait ne
sont pas opposés par exemple utilise le
carnet de vaccination
tout le monde utilise pour voyager ces
questions non mais le carnet de
vaccination c'est une chose les vaccins
obligatoires pour les enfants s'il ya
des choses bon c'est une chose le
passeport vaccinale en soit pour sortir
d'une crise économique
vous vous rendez compte par julien c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
attentatoires aux libertés de
vaccination à la liberté individuelle
tout simplement
et donc aujourd'hui il y a surtout qu'il
y à d'autres méthodes pour sortir de
cette crise il y à une autre méthode
c'est encore une fois de détecter le
coville dans les eaux usées pourquoi
cela aujourd'hui cette méthode de bon
sens n'est pas pratiqué et pourquoi
effectivement il n'y a pas ce qui
permettrait de rouvrir très rapidement
les commerçants les français sont
opposés à l'utilisation d'un passeport
vaccinale mais déjà tous déjà 10 non
seulement ces gestes une atteinte à leur
liberté et ça évidemment bien sûr que
beaucoup de français certainement ils
seront opposés
on peut pas demander à des gens de vous
de se faire vacciner pour aller au bar
vous rendez compte
vous imaginez quelqu'un qui va prendre
son café le matin et qui va devoir des
guinéens passeport mais c'est
complètement délirant
donc à un moment donné il faut quand
même avoir du bon sens les français
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils veulent c'est que
simplement ils veulent retrouver leur
liberté va je retrouve évidemment une
sécurité sanitaire
ils veulent retrouver aussi les
entreprises les restaurateurs je pense
aux commerçants au restaurant au bar qui
aujourd'hui sont en pleine situation de
crise et de faillite et qu'il ne savent
pas de quoi demain sera fait ils vont
pas attendre six mois pour avoir un
passeport vaccinale alors qu'il y avait
jean sylvain clément comment ils
commencent ce passeport national peut
fonctionner en france le rendre je veux
dire faire en sorte qu il
ne porte pas préjudice aux libertés des
français savent et les libertés on ne
parle pas de vaccination obligatoire
alors activement front national était
contre le vaccin aujourd'hui les
français son courrier pour le vaccin
le front national aujourd'hui est opposé
au classement final
s'il se trouve donc se fondre merci pour
que plusieurs pays
s'il se trouve que plusieurs pays le
mettre en place et bien vous courrez
derrière c'est le propre des démagogues
et des poujadistes eux qui n'ont
strictement rien à dire et la firme des
cris provenant pour autant pour autant
nous expliquer qu'on propose rien pour
l'avenir
je ne suis pas aux affaires lubie riche
passé ça serait ça se remarquerait lui
dis n'est pas n'est pas au gouvernement
et lui dit n'est pas dans la majorité
gouvernementale
pas plus que vous d'ailleurs la seule
chose il ya deux ans dans la vie il ya
un la gestion d'urgence
effectivement et il ya la gestion de la
prévision si aujourd'hui la plupart des
pays mondiaux se pose la question de la
mise en place de dispositifs de ce type
bah écoutez moi j'ai tendance à penser
qu' on est ni plus intelligent ni plus
idiot que les danois que les suédois que
les islandais que les grecs que les
habitants des seychelles juste que les
israélites qu'on a besoin d'eux
les seniors filles mary déchets ici il
n'ya que vous que vous qui aujourd'hui
nous expliquer que s'il y avait un porte
parole finale vous ne pourriez plus
aller prendre un café le matin mais rien
ne vous empêchera ensuite c'est quelle
modalité quelles conditions est ce que
c'est un passeport nécessaire pour les
entrées aux frontières s'était mis en
place sur ces chaînes est sûr c'est un
passeport vaccinale nécessaire pour
aller dans un départ on sait
parfaitement que quand la covili on est
sur quelque chose qui est absolument
monstrueux en termes de risque et
d'octobre mortalité donc effectivement
je pense qu'aujourd'hui vouloir
s'interdire de réfléchir aux
possibilités d'essayer de progresser
ensemble
c'est juste un concept à dernière
question est le nom mais l'honneur mais
cette dernière question oui allez y mais
j'ai quand même une dernière question
est ce qu'on n'a pas quand même un train
de retard parce que l'exécutif le
gouvernement nous annonce que tous les
français pourraient être vaccinées d'ici
la fin de l'été donc or c'est dramatique
quand on entendait quand on entend des
discours pareil qui sont aussi peu si
peu lié à la réalité est qu'ils ne
prennent pas encore une forme compte la
détresse financière et économique
aujourd'hui de du d'un pays qui équipe
inquiète d'ailleurs on est au bord d'une
faillite totale
vous avez des gens comme une fois des
petites entreprises des gens qui ne
savent même pas si on peut dire que
chômage chômage et qui ne savent même
pas de quoi demain sera fait à cause de
cette amicale et on leur parle on en
reparlera évolution alors que l'arrivée
excusez moi excusez moi je veux finir
vous allez c'est terminé si vos pairs
j'essaie série s'est terminée voilà je
vous ai laissé finir donc un moment
donné il faut avoir des mesures de bon
sens quand vous voyez qu'aujourd'hui on
peut on peut encore une fois détecté le
coville à travers les eaux usées ça se
fait ça se fait c'est une chose 5 qui
peut se détecte et on peut détecter
l'association a donc facilement accéder
[Musique]
le changer en permanence
voilà non je ne change pas de sujet je
suis en train de si je vous parle de
passe forts maternité lors des deux
musées ça vous dérange ça vous dérange
que je sois interrogées alors je
m'exprime laissez moi vous dire moi je
vous parle de solutions de pour vanessa
terminé la norvège et vous allez
conclure jean philippe dugoin clément
allez vous de vous énerver et cj de
solutions sac est une solution simple
qui existent il faut quand même que les
français le sachent
il s'agit là on le fait déjà et le
nord-bassin de rechercher justement les
trajets réalisés dans les ombres et
généraliser leur effectivement ça con ça
se fait et il faut justement le
généraliser à l'ensemble du territoire
français en tenant compte de la
territorialité et de la circulation du
livre dans tel ou tel territoire
il ya aujourd'hui des parts des zones en
france qui n'ont pas besoin de subir le
courroux de feu conclu en janvier
grandclément on doit terminer on doit
conclure ah oui sous les traits en deux
mots la territorialisation des mesures
ont la défense a fait des mois qu'on se
bagarre pour qu'il n'y ait pas les mêmes
logiques d'un territoire à l'autre en
termes de mesures appliquées ensuite si
aujourd'hui on veut être le seul pays à
s'interdire de réfléchir aux questions
de façon originale de sécurisation
globale apportée à la population
c'est vraiment on est tombé bien bas
justement on a plus de temps vraiment
merci beaucoup et la norvège afin d'être
conseillère rn en paca merci également à
vous jean philippe dugoin clément maire
udi de même si le vice-président de la
région ile-de-france